et bien un bon jour ouais j'ai déménagé
je suis beaucoup trop content de vous
faire cette vidéo je pense que vous
n'imaginez pas à quel point
mais vraiment très peu le savent
vraiment sur la chaîne mais dans la pop
culture que ce soit parmi les films jeux
vidéos séries s'il ya bien une oeuvre
parmi tout ça qui me fait vraiment
vibrer c'est bien la saga final fantasy
et je peux vous dire que ce ff 7 remake
on l'aura attendu
vraiment c'est comme une sorte de rêve
inaccessible mais enfin on y arrive
je ne vous cache pas qu'en 2020 mes
objectifs et mes ambitions d'un petit
peu changé ils évoluent constamment
évidemment et j'ai vraiment envie de
partager plus cet amour que j'ai pour
cette saga sur la chaîne comme je le
faisais au début alors ça ne veut pas
dire que je vais parler que de final
fantasy ne me faites pas dire ce que je
n'ai pas dit c'est juste qu'il y aura
plus souvent des petites vidéos sur
final fantasy des vidéos théorie parmi
ce que je fais déjà entre marvel stars
wars etc
et d'ailleurs j'ai un très gros projet
sur la saga final fantasy mais je n'en
dis pas plus dans tous les cas il est
temps d'enfin traiter de ce final
fantasy 7 remake avec évidemment trois
théories sur le jeu sorti de mon
imaginaire analysons ça ensemble
et évidemment nos l'x lahoud donc vous
êtes prévenus allez c'est parti
[Musique]
je pense qu'il est important de le
rappeler mais final fantasy 7 remake bas
c'est un remake
oui ça fait un peu con de le dire mais
bon nous ne sommes pas sur une reprise
esthétique mais bel et bien un véritable
nouveau jeu se basant sur le final
fantasy 7 originel ce qui sous-entend
bien évidemment qu'il va y avoir
beaucoup de contenu rajouter et nous
avons déjà l'exemple avec l'incroyable
opening movie dans le sens où l'intro
d'origine de ff7 duré environ deux
minutes alors que sur le remake
elle dure plus de 5 et ceci nous montre
clairement ce qui nous attend et les
ambitions de square enix
le jeu est développé et nous montre du
détail
nous arrivons donc à roche ce personnage
introduit dans le remake présenté comme
un soldat de troisième classe
spécialiste de la moto recycle son
identité et son impact dans l'histoire
est très compliqué à définir déjà par
rapport à ff vii d'origine ce personnage
est un âge où ils n'étaient pas là avant
au tout début donc cela sous-entend très
certainement que ce personnage est un
personnage qui restera secondaire voire
optionnel
c'est important je pense de le souligner
mais est-ce véritablement un nouveau
personnage le truc c'est que de par sa
condition de soldats qui indique qu'il
fait partie de la shinra peut souligner
qu'il a connues cloud et celle problème
rappelez-vous de l'intrigué principale
du jeu à propos des origines de cloud
ce dernier est en quête de sa véritable
identité au point de faire une
dépression mentale à un moment donné si
roche a connu cloud par le passé
l'intriguent serait complètement changé
car il révélerait qui était vraiment
cloud et je ne suis pas sûr que le
remake fasse un aussi gros changements
néanmoins ce qui pourrait être
clairement légitime et que le jeu va
mener énormément de nouveaux personnages
non jouables c'est à dire qu'avec ce
remake
square enix va essayer de nous
introduire dans une véritable mégapoles
et capital de
et à la planète donc la shinra sera
normalement beaucoup plus fournie dans
le sens où square enix va
obligatoirement créé plusieurs d'autres
soldats avec des classes différentes
sans parler de crisis core nous avions
que des premières classes dans les faits
vii
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il est
possible que roche ne connaissent pas
cloud et qu'il fasse partie du soldat
peu après les événements qui ont fait
que cloud lui les déserter mais
techniquement cela ne semble pas trop
logique
en tout cas roche pourrait être une
sorte de rivales ou un boss que nous
affronterons régulièrement au fil de
l'aventuré est certainement sur le motor
cycle un peu comme si mournaud ff10 au
vu de ce qui nous est montré dans le
trailer cela ferait sens puisque ce
dernier souhaite affronter cloud de
nouveau mais un facteur sympathie nous
est montrée également ce qui peut
sous-entendre que roche pourrait
assister cloud au fil de l'aventuré et
c'est une pratique courante dans les
final fantasy avec ce genre de
personnage enfin j'admets que square
enix dans leur jeu essaye toujours de
tout relier il se peut que roche est un
lien de près ou de loin avec cloud de
par le passé mais
il faut faire attention car beaucoup
suspectent qu'il pourrait être qu'une
seule par exemple un personnage de
crisis core cependant square enix avait
affirmé qu'il ne prendrait pas en compte
les autres jeux de la compilation ff7 du
moins pour le moment
donc voilà ce que j'ai à dire sur ce
personnage pour le moment alors est-il
un nouveau personnage ou est-il
quelqu'un de déjà connu dans l'univers
a vous de me dire en commentaire moi je
dis que c'est lui car on n'a jamais su
qui il était et il fait partie du passé
de cloud et si j'ai raison bas vous
viendrez à mr réunion histoire de
reconstituer bama véritable forme
[Musique]
bon il est vraiment difficile de deviner
ce que nous prévoit réellement square
enix
les fans de la première heure n'ont pas
pu s'empêcher je pense tout comme moi de
remarquer les différences évidentes
entre fx et remakes et le jeu d'origine
comme la présence de certaines armes
censées arriver plus tard dans
l'aventuré des chimères et une
invocation comme vous voulez comme
léviathan ou des personnages comme
scarlett
tout ça est censé arriver normalement
bien plus tard après l'épopée de midgard
et justement c'est là que les
interrogations commencent final fantasy
7 remake se divisera en plusieurs
parties ce n'est plus un secret pour
personne et la première partie
s'arrêtera normalement à la fin de toute
l'épopée milliards il faut qu'on en
parle et qu'on débatte là dessus car
cela fait vraiment couler beaucoup
d'encre et même moi je faisais partie
des premiers en avoir peur bah oui dans
final fantasy 7 d'origine
bam ilgar symbolise tout l'introduction
du jeu toute la partie où les
personnages principaux s'intègre dans le
scénario scénario qui se construit et
explique les bases du jeu et des
intrigues mais dans ffvii remake midgard
n'a pas la même approche du tout je le
rappelle encore une fois nous sommes sur
un vix mecque et non un reee masters
c'est à dire que midgard sera une
mégapole à taille réelle et n'aura plus
vraiment la même symbolique qu'a
l'époque c'est à dire que maintenant me
guerre du monde
pour cette première partie est censé
être la map en quelque sorte
donc le scénario sera modifiée en
conséquence et s'adaptera à cette mise
en scène
donc oui nous en arrivons à ces féroces
genova et aux jo la grande qualité du
début du scénario de final fantasy 7 et
que tout le monde sait qui s est féroce
bien avant que nous le rencontrions on
nous apprend dans les dialogues qu'il
est un guerrier légendaire vraiment
surpuissant bref on a peur de lui
alors que nous ne l'avons jamais
rencontré et la première fois où nous
sommes censés le voir c'est durant le
passage en bateau pour costa del sol
bien évidemment vous connaissez des
intrigues mais est-ce du coup vraiment
ces féroces que nous rencontrons amis de
gare d'après moi il n'ya pas tant de
changements que ça sur sa présence cela
a juste été décalée en quelque sorte
spoiler alert et oui il s'agit pour moi
toujours de genova qui a pris la forme
de ses finances il n'y a absolument
aucune raison que nous soyons face au
véritable ces féroces
vous connaissez l'histoire surtout que
nous le voyons disparaître par la suite
en face de rouge 13 et d'aeris et
qu'après genova apparaît pour moi cela
juste été décalés le truc c'est que la
version playstation 1 n'était pas
toujours explicite du au graphisme au
vieux dialogue sans voix bref c'était
une autre époque quoi mais ici square
enix peut se faire plaisir vraiment
surtout et notamment nous montrer plus
en détail le pouvoir de métamorphose de
genova passons à aux jo ce qui est
intéressant avec ce dernier que
normalement il ne reconnaît pas cloud
toutes les normes intrigue concernant la
théorie de la réunion se dit mystifie
lors de la première venue du groupe à la
grotte nord dues aux explications de
hojo qui reconnaît cloud or dans ce qui
nous est montré dans le remake aux jo a
accès à toutes les caméras de milliards
ce qui veut dire que ce dernier épie les
moindres faits et gestes de cloud
car oui aux jo n'est pas vraiment témoin
du comportement et des agissements de
cloud lors de son périple dans le final
fantasy 7 d'origine avant les événements
de la grotte nord je ne sais pas si je
suis vraiment clair mais
c'est un élément énorme du scénario qui
est en quelque sorte modifié car dans le
remake aux jo voit la faiblesse de cloud
et son comportement envers le fossé
féroce mais là où cette intelligente et
kodjo est toujours dans l'ombre
donc cela n'aurait pas vraiment d'impact
sur l'histoire et je dirais même qu'il
va servir pour le viewer
effectivement il affirme que sa théorie
fonctionne et qu'il espère qu'il ne le
décevra pas tout comme pour le joueur ou
quelqu'un comme moi qui espère que ces
théories sont bonnes et qu'évidemment
que le jeu sera un grand succès aux jo
servirait de point de vue omniscient
afin que le joueur puisse mieux
appréhender le scénario déjà bien
compliquée
pour conclure j'aimerais vous parler des
invocations pour les vétérans de final
fantasy 7 les invocations était
disponible après tout la partie de
midgard avec notamment la vocation du
chocobo morgue et les invocations était
justement sous forme de materia de
couleur rouge
final fantasy 7 fait partie des vieux
final fantasy et tetsuya nomura n'avait
donc pas créé de background spécifique
pour ces dernières la place d'ailleurs
des invocations dans cet opus est
vraiment assez surprenante car rien ne
nous est expliqué les invocations relève
normalement du mythe de la légende des
pouvoirs très ancien et badoit ff7 cela
se révèle être plus de la collection de
pokémon qu'autre chose malgré leurs
grandes puissances ah bah oui mais je
suis désolé je reçois de matériel rouge
me fais à bastille léger aucune histoire
dessus et puis au final je me rends
compte que c'est une créature qui est
dedans et qu'il faut monter niveau avec
les apps et il manquait plus que le
professeur chen pour me demander si au
début je voulais léviathan ifrit ou
bahamut
ouais il n'y a pas de petits plants donc
j'ai pris bahamut bon je faire un petit
peu en roue libre
mais bon c'est cette gaieté de coeur
bref tout ça pour dire que je pense
sérieux quelque chose qui va changer
avec le remake
depuis les derniers final fantasy les
invocations possède désormais toujours
un background assez fourni il suffit de
regarder ff 15 avec carrément on peut le
dire les personnages entre guillemets de
bahamut shiva ou encore ifrit et ce sera
très certainement le cas également dans
ce final fantasy 7 remake
je vous explique mon idée durant le
trailer nous faisons face à léviathan
nous avons même déjà vu shiva et ifrit
donc je suis d'accord que si le jeu se
passe entièrement à mes gars square enix
a voulu accélérer l'obtention de ces
dernières mais nous ne sommes pas face à
un simple reboot
le scénario est censé être largement
plus fournis et on en vient à la scène
où nous voyons scarlett tout comme les
invocations scarlett est censé
apparaître après les événements de
milliards et si elle est présente dès
maintenant c'est qu'elle va apporter du
background à l'histoire par rapport au
trailer et
sa condition scarlett est tout de même à
la tête du pôle du développement des
armes de la shinra cette dernière
pourrait bien être à l'origine de la
conception des matériels d'invocation
qui sont de couleur rouge
effectivement les matériels sont un
concentré de macau et voir scarlett créé
des matériels de couleur rouge ou très
chaude ou laissent clairement sous
entendre qu'elle serait liée aux
invocations et qu'elle pourrait même
s'en servir ce sont ces armes et point
intéressant scarlett est plus ou moins
liés à barrett par rapport à son passé
intégré scarlett pourrait amener un
nouvel arc dans l'histoire de final
fantasy 7 remake lié à barrett et ces
dernières un boss récurrents où chaque
combat serait à la manière de dr sid
dans final fantasy xii
scarlett accompagné d'une invocation que
nous gagnerions suite à la victoire du
groupe sur l'ennemi
on arrive à la fin de cette vidéo je
suis désolé j'avais plus de place sur
l'appareil
merde ce que ça fait du bien de parler
de final fantasy c'est vraiment un truc
de ouf
et bien sachez que je me faire plaisir
que j'ai vraiment profité de ff7 remake
pour vous en parler un petit peu plus
sachez d'ailleurs que je serai présent à
paris manga 2020 avec aero on y sera
tous les deux en duo donc si vous y êtes
n'hésitez pas à venir nous voir c'est
vraiment une occasion de ouf
sur ce je vous souhaite une agréable
continuation écoutez bas c'était arcoroc
on se voit prochainement et puis pas
si t'es pas venir à la réunion comme ça
vous me ramènerait les cellules du line
up aller
[Musique]